hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast voyage into the
captivating realm of cannabis science
and its regulation presented by Jason
Lupo a PhD a consulting scientist an
analytical chemist at the RJ Lee group
I'm Judy Oracle black roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots
leopards is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located in the
far left of your screen type your
question into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having the
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Lupo I will now turn the presentation
over to him good afternoon everybody
thank you for coming to tuning in and
listening to my presentation this
afternoon you know I think it was in the
early 1970s that a book was written
about cannabis legalization and cannabis
science science and a good friend of the
author was the esteemed astronomer Carl
Sagan and when the when Carl Sagan found
out that the author had predicted that
cannabis would be legalized within ten
years he said why so pessimistic he
thought cannabis would be legalized much
sooner than 10 years but fast forward
nearly 50 years later and here we are
now finally talking about cannabis
legalization and more importantly
to guys like myself cannabis science and
it's regulation today I'm hailing to you
from Pennsylvania and I think that you
know in my own lifetime I never would
have suspected that cannabis would be
legalized and that I would be here in
Pennsylvania talking to you about
cannabis and I think that's in no small
way due to the efforts of guys like
rusty awesomo and Tom forego of the
Pennsylvania medical cannabis Society
and really all of the Pennsylvania
medical cannabis society helping to lay
the foundation for us to be speaking at
events like beets while I'm thanking
folks I also wanted to thank my
colleagues at our JV group we are the
auditing body for the state of
Washington so we audit all of the
cannabis labs and so therefore I wanted
to also acknowledge the Washington State
liquor and cannabis Board for granting
us the opportunity to help labs enhance
their science and make sure that they're
putting out defendable defendable data I
also wanted to thank terpenes and
testing magazine a publication of which
I recently became editor-in-chief and
this gives me a great opportunity to
work with the stellar team at terpenes
and testing magazine to help disseminate
sound analytical science and
cutting-edge technology and of course
I'd like to thank lab roots for giving
me the opportunity to speak to you all
today I've broken my presentation up
into four main themes or sections but
I'd like you all to be thinking about
two other overarching themes while we
have this discussion today I'd like you
to be thinking about number one we're
putting one number on packaging for
cannabis products so when a patient goes
into a dispensary and they're looking at
the potency of a product they'll often
see one number listed there but there's
a lot of different things that kind of
go into that one number that a lab might
produce and so I kind of I wanted to
walk you through some of those
scientific variant variations and other
sources of variation that can ultimately
lead to that one number I also wanted
wanted you all to be thinking about
targeted therapies so users being able
to know what
of products they should be selecting
when they walk into a dispensary and and
when they're specifically trying to
target individual ailments that they
might have before I meet before I begin
with some of the scientific acts aspects
of the presentation I first wanted to
introduce a little bit more about who
our j-league group is beyond our
cannabis lab audits our headquarters is
shown in the lower image there that's
that's outside of Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania in Monroeville Pennsylvania
we also have in the upper image the lab
front of the Washington State location
in Pasco Washington we recently put a
lab up at Penn State University in State
College and we've also that lab space
down at Oak Ridge National Lab our GT
group has been part of a lot of really
high profile projects through the years
and I wanted to share with you some of
those projects that kind of make us who
we are here today one of the things that
we do routinely is medical device
services so often when somebody is
pitching a medical device to the medical
community for use they have to first put
that device through a series of tests
such as corrosion tests wear tests and
the FDA recrop requires all of this and
these are routine services that we
provide to make sure that at the end
patients are safe whenever they're
having medical devices implanted in
their bodies we've also analyzed the the
water in our public school systems to
make sure that our children are drinking
healthy uncontaminated water
we've also we were one of the first labs
to generate methodology for the toy we
call of a few years back we were
evaluating toys to make sure that they
did not contain toxic substances or
elements that that you know children may
be poisoned with when they're putting
toys like this in their mouths or just
when they're handling them in general we
recording to help identify the cause of
an explosion of an oil derrick and you
know obviously to help of the company
make sure that this didn't happen in the
future similarly we were called in after
a train derailment that cascaded a toxic
substance entity into the environment we
were called in to help analyze the
environmental impact and the safety of
the community surrounding that I don't
think anybody will ever forget where
they were on September 11th I know I
know that I won't our JV group was the
first lab to characterize specifically
what World Trade Center dust was that
was pervasive throughout the throughout
of Manhattan in the surrounding areas
this was pervasive people were breathing
it and it was also inside of businesses
and required cleaning up more recently
and a project that I've been directly
associated with we've started to analyze
particulate captured through a device
that we helped invent on our
international space station to to
analyze the particles that our
astronauts and our scientists are
breathing and so now our our reach is
extended from the oceans to the heavens
with this project because we are an
analytical laboratory we have a lot of
accreditation and I think this is
important because at the outset I said
that we are auditors for the state of
Washington and yet we are consistently
getting audited ourselves ourselves for
these various accreditation --zz that we
have and so not only do we know what to
do when we are auditors but we also know
what to do when we are being audited and
I think that becomes important when
we're trying to share with labs proper
proper proper methodologies and proper
compliance most recently we received the
DEA scheduled to license to be able to
analyze schedule 2 drugs now we're very
similar to some ISIL accreditation
programs in a few facets we are we are
analyzing a checklist with the labs you
know the states have defined code that a
lab must be compliant to and so we
evaluate whether labs in Washington are
indeed compliant with what the state of
Washington requires we do go in and
audit these labs sometimes these labs
can be scheduled sometimes they can be
spontaneous and we also evaluate
proficiency test results as do I so
accreditation programs but we also
provide some services that are
additional to those three that you see
listed in green at the top and two that
I wanted to point out specifically are
that we hope to draft the regulations in
Washington state often regulators are
not scientists and so they may not know
specifically what might be practical for
a laboratory to be doing on a routine
basis and so we tried to help introduce
some practical practical verbiage into
these regulations to help labs comply
more easily we also supply analytical
and regulatory consultation to both the
labs and the state of Washington and and
I you know I wanted to express a little
bit more about that you know the
regulator's typically are not scientists
and they might not understand everything
that's going on in the cannabis lab from
a scientific or an instrumental
perspective and so we can help them
understand what labs are saying when
they might have some comments on the
code we've also helped guide
laboratories to better comply with the
state's requirements often laboratories
are confused by some of the regulations
and not quite sure what they need to be
doing to be compliant and we've helped
serve as a liaison between those labs
and the regulators at the bottom I found
this chemists Creed and I think this is
quite profound for what not only my own
objectives are with my involvement in
the cannabis industry but also what our
JV groups goals are as a whole and I'm
not gonna read this all to you you can
see it there for yourselves but
essentially it discusses you know
propagating a true understanding of
chemical science and avoiding false or
exaggerated statements discouraging
practices that are harmful to public
interest or welfare if that doesn't
summarize what our objectives are I
don't know quite what does so I wanted
to talk a little bit about some cannabis
science but I first wanted to talk about
some cannabis history and the rationale
for this is I think that a lot of people
might assume that this is a new topic
because it's more prevalent in the media
but in fact cannabis is nothing new it's
it's in its earliest known usage was
about 10,000 years ago as a fiber in
what is now modern-day Taiwan it's been
medicinal used since about 20 27 37 BCE
those uses were first developed in China
but it wasn't until William of
Shaughnessy introduced therapeutic uses
to the West at around 1842 that Western
society began to take notice
O'Shaughnessy developed a study
commissioned by the British government
when he was in India and he was studying
therapeutic uses of hemp and of cannabis
in the early 1930s major drug
manufacturers such as Eli Lilly or Parke
Davis began preparing cannabis products
but the 1937 infamous marijuana Tax Act
basically kind of squashed a lot of the
research and indeed the the product line
that many companies had generated now
this did not make cannabis illegal but
it did put a hefty tax of $100 per ounce
on cannabis to transfer cannabis and so
no one could really afford this we all
know that in the late 60s and early 70s
there was a boom in cannabis usage again
and major drug companies again began
developing cannabis derived products and
I think that that's interesting that
throughout you know from the 30s
throughout the 70s and even to today
with companies like GW Pharma
pharmaceuticals pharmaceutical companies
are not doubting the efficacy of these
types of products states begin
decriminalizing cannabis around 1973 the
first state being Oregon but it wasn't
until 1996 in California that the
cannabis became medically legal and then
again in 2012 Colorado and Washington
followed suit with being the first
states to make
animus recreationally legal now
everything with cannabis starts with
trichomes so trichomes are glands that
are on the the plant you can see in the
bottom-left figure it looks like the
plant might have frost or dew on it
those are indeed the trichomes and these
plans contain the cannabinoids and the
terpenes the molecules that you know
anybody involved in the cannabis
industry or after but they serve in
nature as protection from insects and
animals or fungal growth these these
trichomes are highly volatile they're
fragile things like heat light physical
contact oxygen and time can dispense
these contents and so it's it's very
it's very paramount that people are
practicing caution when they're working
with these types of materials inside of
those trichomes are phyto cannabinoids
phyto cannabinoids differentiate from
endocannabinoids that our body naturally
produces and I've shown 8/8 individual
cannabinoids here but in fact you know
there are said to be more than 90
cannabinoids in cannabis and I went with
the conservative reference the frontiers
and plant science reference that you see
at the bottom right of the screen the
different sources on the Internet can
provide different levels of how many
cannabinoids are actually reported but I
think it's important to note here that
while some of these structures look very
similar they all have different
chemistry's and so this starts to lead
into the sources of variation when
you're looking at different strains or
even within different flowers of the
same strain on the right hand side of
this of this slide you can see a table
of different boiling points of the
different cannabinoids and this becomes
important for users who are vaporizing
products and maybe they have a vaporizer
that has a digital beat out and they can
set it to a specific temperature this
can help users then target cannabinoids
that they know are useful for their
specific ailments these cannabinoids all
start in the plant as what's called CBG
a and very over
of enzymes in native to the plant they
are then they are then transformed into
other cannabinoids though that we know
such as THC a CBD a for example now THC
a is those is the highest concentration
cannabinoid in the in the plant and so
this this cannabinoid is not
psychoactive and it's through the act of
heating where the fancy term is
decarboxylation that this cannabinoid is
then transformed into what's called
Delta 9 THC now this is the main
psychoactive component of cannabis and
it's important to note that when labs
are analyzing these types of
cannabinoids it's extremely important
for edibles manufacturers to know if
there is indeed THC a in their product
because it is not psychoactive and if
they end up putting THC a into their
gummy bears for example then what you
ended up buying is a glorified batch of
gummy bears that have no psychoactive
properties I find it really interesting
that you know often we talk about with
with cannabis with any product with any
pharmaceutical product that we might
have in our medical in our medicine
shelves that you know if it's if it's
old is it does it still work is there
still some efficacy to it and I find it
interesting that with cannabis when the
main psychoactive ingredient Delta 9 THC
degrades it creates what's called
cannabinol or CBN and cannabinol is is
indicative of the freshness of the plant
material but often it's not them at very
high levels if you go into a dispensary
you're not really gonna see egregious
levels of cbn on a product label
but i think more importantly this has
been found to be useful as a sleeping
aid and so i think that's the
interesting part that when the main
ingredient of cannabis THC degrades
there still is something useful to be
had from it and in CBM we have
cannabinoid receptors in our body
there's two types of cannabinoid
receptors there see
receptors which are found mostly in the
brain and their cb2 receptors which are
found mostly in the immune system and
while this slide kind of over simplifies
the relationship you know sort of this
lock and key fit between cannabinoids
and cannabinoid receptors which is not
really which is not really accurate the
main take-home message behind this slide
if you look at that the schematic of the
body on the right is all of those
colored dots correspond to where
cannabinoid receptors have been found
and so it's thought that because they're
distributed all over the body this is
what allows cannabis to be so useful
there's so many different ailments I
think one thing that's important to note
is that it's there's not you don't have
the possibility of overdosing it's a
physiological impossibility and this is
in part due to several things the body
produces endocannabinoids itself and
cannabinoids are known to limit
excessive activity so essentially they
tell other neurotransmitters to cool it
when they're firing too fast so this is
a sort of a homeostasis mechanism and
it's recently been found that there's a
hormone in our bodies called
pregnenolone that when we ingest too
much THC this the levels of this hormone
go up and so it's kind of pumping the
brakes on the effects of THC importantly
cannabinoids receptors are not located
in the brainstem which is an area
controlling respiration and so this is
one of the key contrasts to how users of
opiates can overdose because there are
opioid receptors in the brain stem but
still it's important to check dosages
because although one cannot overdose on
THC a user may not be able to handle the
effects of high doses and so it's always
important to dose accurately but there's
been a lot of cool uses of cannabis
touted many of them are listed on this
wheel that can be found on the website
Leafly but I think the take-home message
behind this slide is that it's a it's a
misconception
to think that THC is not medicinal I've
often heard people say well THC is what
gets you high but CBD is the medicinal
cannabinoid that's just simply not true
and if you look at many of these
different ailments on here you can see
that THC is indeed useful for for many
of these from a medicinal perspective
now when you walk into a dispensary
they're gonna want you to smell lots of
things now this the smells that you will
you will be smelling have nothing to do
with cannabinoids or potency but they
have everything to do with terpenes now
I could talk to you all about routines
all day but suffice to say for now these
are derived from isoprene units so the
top left molecule and the pictures above
they are the primary constituents of
essential oils that are found in
medicinal plants these are used in
nature to repel predators and lower
pollinators and they're responsible for
the flavor and aroma of cannabis strains
now I've read that there's over 200
terpenes found in cannabis and again
it's one of those numbers that when you
consult different sites on the internet
you'll find a lot of different numbers
as well but I went conservative again
now these terpenes can help introduce
something that I'm referring to as
strain individuality I've heard some
growers talk about terpenes and how if
they're if they're producing if they're
cultivating a unique strain unique to
their specific grow house and the guy
down the street is also claiming to have
that same strain by comparing the
terpene profiles you can you can thereby
have a fingerprint of whether those
strains are indeed the same or whether
there are differences and they're not
the same strain there's a lot of
different dirt beans as we talked about
on the last slide I just wanted to share
a few with you some of the more common
terpenes to cannabis there's mersin
Burstein is the main root pain and many
hops and so if you're a fan of IPAs like
myself and you see all these little
nuances between the different beers the
different scent and flavor profiles that
has a lot to do with the hops that are
being used to produce the beer Mersin is
also the main
the most common turn being produced by
cannabis it's thought that nursing hopes
cannabinoid effects occur more quickly
and this is due to helping the
cannabinoid pass across the blood-brain
barrier more readily additionally it's
thought that nursing helps increase the
maximum saturation level of CBD cb1
receptor and so strains higher in Mersin
are thought to give a greater
psychoactive effect so those last two
bullet points there
kind of show you the synergy that can be
had between having the terpene present
with the cannabinoid immersing has also
been been been shown it in the
literature to be an inhibitor of gastric
and duodenal ulcers another common
terpene to cannabis is carry a finally
you know this is the terpene that gives
black things like black pepper they're
characteristic spicy aromas and it's the
only known turn pain to interact with
the endocannabinoid system so again
there's this synergy between the
cannabinoid and the terpene carry a
filing has been studied in cancer
treatments chronic pain treatments
arthritis and things like neuropathy to
name a few we're all familiar with
limonene if we've ever used an orange
based or citrus based cleaner that was
derived from natural products limonene
is formed from pining in nature and it's
thought that limonene promotes a
positive or uplifting mood or attitude
importantly at least for topical
applications limonene has been shown to
help other terpenes readily absorb
through the skin and tissue we use
limonene as a cleaner B due to its
antifungal and antibacterial properties
and it's also known to be a natural
insecticide pi9 is the most widely
encountered terpene in nature and if
you've ever walked through a forest and
you felt like you can breathe a lot
better it's because pining has been
shown to be an expectorant and a
bronchodilator so it's quite important
in respiration lastly there's little one
of my personal favorites linen wool is
what gives labs and things like lavender
and bear demo it's their their
characteristic sense
Linna wool was thought to produce a
calming
relaxing effect and it's also thought to
be a sleep aid so one can now see if
we're taking some CBN that we talked
about on a previous slide and where and
which is known to be a sleeping aid and
we're adding in some women perhaps we
have a more effective sleeping aid it's
also thought that linen wool helps
lessen THC induced anxiety and so if
there's new users to the industry and
they're worried about you know THC
induced paranoia or anxiety perhaps
finding strains with winnable our higher
concentrations of Lin alone will help
lessen those effects so we talked about
on the last slide the synergy between
these cannabinoids and these terpenes
and that's something that that was
talked about in a paper by ethan russo
which is cited at the bottom of the
slide and it was called the entourage
effect and so on this slide we see a
recreation of some tables that were in
that paper and so on the left there are
some some different terpenes found in
cannabis the column just to the right is
what types of plants these are commonly
found in besides cannabis the column
that says phonological activity shows a
variety of the different medical
ailments that these these terpenes have
been studied in and all of those
correspond to specific medical studies
that are cited in in the review paper
cited below and i think the important
take-home message here is that these
researchers of these various medical
studies evaluating when the cannabinoids
by themselves had as high of an efficacy
for treating these different ailments
versus having the cannabinoid in
conjunction with the terpene and it's
been found repeatedly that having that
terpene present helps these cannabinoids
better do their job now again when they
when that when a patient walks into a
dispensary they're gonna be bombarded
with lots of different strain strain
names so strain names like Obama or
Michael Phelps tell you nothing
the chemistry of the sample and so what
it really boils down to is having an
understanding of what the different set
profiles are because that's what you're
gonna be asked to be smelling they're
gonna open the jar and you're gonna
smell this and and if you can kind of
train your nose to know that well
strains that have a citrus smell or like
lightly high in limonene and limonene
has been used in these various studies
for treating medical ailments then you
can better select strains that might be
might help you combat your medical
ailments with a more targeted approach
another thing that's a big conundrum in
the industry is this debate of cannabis
indica versus cannabis sativa and I like
this graphic because they made it a nice
periodic table and after all I am a
chemist but you know you can see that
there's some indicas on the left and
some hybrids in the centre and green and
some sativas on the right in red now
there's a variety of characteristics
sort of anecdotal descriptions of what
these different strains can do but this
is all relative to an individual you
know I've heard people talk about
sativas being uplifting or or energizing
I knew somebody that referred to these
as clean the house strains because he
felt like he could clean his house much
more effectively then you have indicas
which are thought to be couch lock
strains so you're definitely not going
to be cleaning your house then you have
strains in the middle that perhaps might
you know might give you kind of the best
of both worlds
but the real the real picture behind
indica and sativa are much are not
really these anecdotal stories told by
bud tenders but it's more morphological
differences so indicas are used to
growing in harsher environments think
Nepal or India the cush region and
they're dense they're short stubby they
have broad leaves they produce a thick
THC resin to help aid in protecting them
from the harsh harsher environments that
they're found in they're known to have
high
CBD content than sativas and they have
faster flowering times than sativas
sativa is on the other hand hail from
much warmer climates to think Mexico or
Columbia or Thailand
these are Thailand wean they have less
broad leaves and they have longer
flowering times that's the that's really
the true picture behind indica and
sativa these other types of anecdotal
differences are more are much more on an
individual by individual basis
there's also consistently a debate of
flowers versus concentrates you know in
Pennsylvania they're not selling flower
at the outset which I find strange but
people that are in serious pain they
need something that's fast-acting and
flower has been shown to be fast-acting
concentrates especially if it's inedible
those are going to take much longer to
to basically start taking effect but
flower the the the high from ingesting
flower is much shorter than the highs
from ingesting and edible flowers
definitely contain terpenes you can
smell these concentrates may or may not
contain terpenes as terpenes are very
volatile and they can essentially bake
off during the extraction process but
nowadays many many manufacturers are
adding terpenes back in to have to give
users still those characteristic scent
profiles from a given strain flowers
obviously have a very complex matrix we
talked about all of the different
chemical constituents of a flower that
you know some of the main ones at least
the cannabinoids in the terpenes so this
essentially creates this picture of a
very strong natural variation there can
be headstrong variation going up and
down a plant from different buds on the
plant - you know flowers across harvest
concentrates are thought to be much more
homogeneous unless it's an edible again
where where the the amount of the
cannabinoids might not be equivalently
distributed across something like a
candy bar I think it's very important
for people to understand that what's
products label when it's flour is not
the sample being purchased so if you go
into a dispensary or you get lab data
back from you know from your from your
lab and it says 25% THC a for example
what's being purchased in the dispensary
likely is not 25% and this is again due
to the natural variation when when flour
is submitted to a lab for analysis and
we'll talk about this a little bit later
but it's it's not fairly representative
of the entire harvest and so it's users
need to exercise caution when they're
reading these product labels and when
they're when they're self tight trading
or dosing I think it's also important to
note that you know with flour if you're
burning it if you're smoking it there's
going to be combustion byproducts so a
lot of people have started to go to
concentrates you know thinking that
these are cleaner and in many ways they
can be and they started to vaporize the
concentrates flour can contain small
levels of pesticides but it's been shown
that that if if the flour is not clean
if there's pesticides on the flour these
pesticides can indeed concentrate in the
extracts that are being produced but I
wanted to show this plot here this this
the wildest this citation may be fairly
archaic 1982 I think it shows a pretty
good pretty useful point here in that
this compares this was from a medical
study where there was people that were
smoking cannabis there was people that
had an IV of the active product
ingredient Delta 9 THC and there was
people that had some some type of oil
product and you can see that the smoking
in the IV nearly parallel to each other
in the rated high which is listed along
the y-axis and you can see that they
also have very similar degradation
profiles you know down to about two
hundred and forty minutes or four hours
but the the world consumption took much
longer to reach its its pinnacle of the
rated high but it also lasted much
longer when we when we do orally
consumed THC not very
much of it actually makes it into the
bloodstream and this is because of the
metabolism of THC in the body
you know it's rapidly degraded in the
liver so it's thought that again less
than 10% is actually delivered to the
bloodstream but the molecule in the
center of the slide 11 hydroxy Delta 9
THC is what is produced in the body
through this metabolism and it's thought
that this has about the same potency as
Delta 9 THC which could explain then why
these sorts of edibles last much longer
because even though the THC is degraded
it's creating something that's still
psychoactive and then the carboxy THC is
a metabolite of the 11 hydroxy Delta 9
THC and this is the main cannabinoid
that things like like urine tests or
drug tests are looking to find okay so
we've talked a lot about different
chemical variations but there's a lot of
other variations that need that people
need to be aware of when when they're
considering purchasing these products or
creating products where the cultural
variations can significantly affect the
potency of a product and this could be
things through lightly you know things
like lighting the different nutrients
that growers are using soil and water
quality temperature and relative
humidity you know how you're controlling
contamination and pests the harvest time
the curing process all of those things
matter and as brothers
you know consistently try to hone their
craft as artisans they're often changing
these things which can also change the
potency of their harvest their sample
matrix variations you know at the top
left these are these are kind of cycling
through in an order of lowest to highest
potency but there's there's things like
Keef when when when Keef is is
compressed it's called hash there's
there's these oils they're shatter
there's resins there's roses there's
butters and
you see what a THC or a cannabinoid in
general isolate would look like a white
white powder but it goes beyond that
there's pizzas there's ice cream that
there's funny honey there's sweet Racha
sauce were made chocolates these all
present different matrices that a lab
would have to to be able to analyze
there's even on the bottom right
cannabis infused wine and so all of
these matrices present challenges that
an analytical laboratory would have to
to overcome to be able to successfully
extract out the representative amounts
of the cannabinoid such that they can be
putting accurate product labels on all
of these different medicinal products
there's there's also variations that can
stem from sampling protocols so who
obtains the sample for the lab for the
lab tests is a trained lab staff or is
it a gross selecting samples in Colorado
for example it was the grow that was
selecting the samples or the
manufacturer was selecting samples to
submit to the lab for analysis
here in Pennsylvania the the lab staff
needs to go out into the into the grow
house and acquire a representative
amount of sample so that's that's quite
important because the laboratory needs
to make sure that they're not
contaminating the grow house by coming
in from the outside and acquiring these
samples so they need to be making sure
they're they're using proper personal
protective equipment things like gloves
lab coats you know they also need to be
ensuring that they have clean sampling
tools I was in a grow house once in
Canada and I I was asked to wear a
full-body suit overalls I was asked to
wear a hairnet a beard net booties
before I put the booties on I needed
this did my feet in and my shoes into a
sanitizing foot bath and I never even
set foot inside the actual grow I was
just in the portion of the building that
housed the grow so what steps are are
people taking to prevent contamination
those are quite important and also is
the amount of
by the lab truly representative again
and in a few slides I would argue that
it is not at least with flower but there
are methods that are available that
discussed sampling specifically the USP
USP 40 and ASTM also has a method that
discusses sampling again these are not
specific to cannabis just yet but they
do provide at least a foundation for a
laboratory to be considering whenever
they're going to be going into a grow
house and sampling products to analyze
there's very instant analytical methods
I've heard a lot of people say you know
I took three different sample I took
this three Alec watts of the same sample
and I sent it off to three different
labs and I got three different answers
but I would expect that as an analytical
chemist unless the laboratories are all
doing the exact same protocol many labs
are not there are not standardized
methods in this industry that all labs
are adhering to and so unless it unless
a lab is doing the same thing as the
other labs that you send your samples
off to it's not a true apples to apples
comparison there can be a lot of sources
of variation introduced by the
analytical testing methodologies
themselves and this can include things
like different instruments you know if
you're doing HPLC different solvents the
different grades of solvents that people
could be using how often they maintain
their equipment and how they maintain
their equipment how often they calibrate
their instrument you know I've I've seen
a lot of diversity and how often labs
calibrate some labs calibrate weekly
some labs calibrate much it much in a
much longer duration sometimes monthly
what's the sensitivity of the equipment
you know how what's the lowest levels
that can detect of course there's going
to be an analyst area you know what's
the skill of the people in the
laboratory have they been properly
trained are they qualified and of course
we talked about all of the different
sample matrices that that can introduce
significant variants so you get a
situation like it's this guy's bath
water
well that's what happens in this
industry from a consumer perspective and
and from people receiving laboratory
data they don't understand all of these
different sources of variation are going
to lead to different numbers I would not
expect people to be getting the same
numbers every single time
especially what's a plant that's so
highly variable that contains over 500
chemical constituents we talked about
the natural variation in the planet but
kept the chemistry we talked about
growing conditions we did not really
talk about genetics but it's been shown
that different strain names which are
nothing more than a marketing tool may
actually be genetically the same as
other strains we talked about all the
different types of products that are
available in the market and sampling and
analytical methods all of these things
result in you know combine to result in
those one numbers that are being put on
product labels they you know with with
no real error associated with that
product label so I think at this point
of the seminar I want to switch gears a
little bit and kind of talk about how we
at our JV group have tried to help labs
at least combat the latter source of
error that we talked about and that's
error and variance due to the analytical
lab processes themselves you know we've
all seen headlines like that that's from
1928 these headlines that are much more
current you know cannabis lab testing is
the industry's dirty little secrets you
know that the federal growhouse down in
Mississippi has more tea samples and no
federal testing standards these types of
headlines
only are deal it serious to this
industry they serve no one and any good
and I think that they're much too
pervasive we've seen things you know on
our lab audits is this quest for the
highest potency number and that backdrop
there from high times they say the
strongest strain on earth was 34 percent
THC we've seen things like the top
bullet point there where you know can
you do me a favor this was published in
the stranger an article called can we
trust pot labs can you do me a favor and
not post any flower results under 20%
wheels under
75 or hash under 40% and then the client
asks the lab if you do get a sample
that's below these results I'll get you
another sample for retest while
retesting in the state of Washington is
illegal this is not a permitted activity
another lab that we we audited during as
you know a surprise audit we found that
a Keefe sample said greater than 70% THC
a and a blue dream sample said it was
greater than 38 percent THC a I asked
this lab is that the strongest strain on
earth and why is that not in high times
the strongest rain in the drew backdrop
was 34% now I think it's interesting
that you can see here that that you know
with some of the below bullet points
that these numbers you know could be
accurate at least from the Keith's
perspective it's known that it could be
as high as 70% but these numbers threw
up a red flag to us and as auditors we
needed to do our due diligence and make
sure that we were investigating this so
then ultimately patients can be trusting
what's on product labels this is
probably my favorite case study that I
will share with you and it's important
to beware of the manipulation of data
I'll say it later but I'll say it again
here just because something looks
scientific doesn't make it so this piece
of data there's there's five labs that
were plotted and then a supposed suspect
lab now this does not represent all of
the laboratories in the state of
Washington why all of the laboratories
weren't plotted is unknown but you know
they're pointing out this sort of
industry average but again there's no
error associated with these values and
and measurements without error values
are pretty much devoid of meaning
especially to an analytical chemist but
we've provided the error for you and you
can see that the average is roughly
about 20 percent in the error at one
standard deviation and one Sigma is
about five percent so we're saying 20
plus or minus five so that gives you a
range of anywhere between 15 and 25
percent
the suspected lab was at 23% well within
the range of the average when you
included error but another way this
shows you all of the labs the suspect
lab is listed as the next-to-last and
you can see that that mean line through
the center it goes right through that
lab and you can see that not only not
only that but you can see that there are
other labs also that could have been
targeted by this person putting out this
manipulated data and we're not so it's
quite important that people understand
data it can clearly be manipulated to
serve the purpose of the person
manipulating that data but a lot of labs
do proficiency tests and these are
designed to help auditors assess whether
that lab is good but just because a lab
passes a proficiency test doesn't really
transfer that that lab is indeed a good
lab or a quality analytical laboratory
these proficiency tests have some
limitations right now in that you know
one of which is the potency is not in a
cannabis matrix often these labs are
evaluating a much simpler matrix of a
cannabinoid in methanol or some solvent
and so it's not giving them this complex
matrix that extracting these
cannabinoids from cannabis would give
also there's a very wide accepted range
so if you look at those tolerance limits
the lower limit fix for example for n
butane was about 64 ppm while the upper
limit was 774 ppm so the laboratory just
needed to basically be somewhere between
there and they passed that's much much
too wide of a range to be considered
sound analytical data there are some
positives of the proficiency test though
recently at least some of these tests
have been sent in hent matrices which
aren't able to be shipped across state
lines and so this has started to
introduce some higher complexity into
the into the labs evaluation but again
are they truly representative of
lab skill I would submit that they are
not there have been labs permanently
shut down that past their PT tests and I
think that this is this could be in part
due to you know what's known as the best
behavior mentality when you know that
you're being tested you're gonna try to
do the best job that you can and you
know perhaps behind closed doors things
start to unravel and things become more
chaotic and runners start to be cut and
then you start to see some of the the
problems and the lacks of compliance in
the laboratory that have been pervasive
in the media consistently preventive
strong challenge for labs and I think
abs are often thrown under the bus for
not producing accurate data there on the
right you see an article that was
published in the Denver Post some time
ago and they were basically explaining
that all of these manufacturers on the
Left we're not you know putting in the
amount of active product ingredient THC
into the product that they were
advertising but we can look at this plot
in two different ways we could say
either a the manufacturer wasn't doing
their due diligence and was essentially
ripping off the consumer or we could say
that the lab was not accurately
representing what the manufacturer did
indeed put in the product and in these
it's important to note that these
cannabinoids are what's called
lipophilic molecules they they love fats
and oils and so a lot of these edibles
like if you consider a brownie or a
baked good there's gonna be fats there's
going to be a oils and so an inefficient
extraction of these out of there because
the cannabinoids are kind of holding
onto these fats and oils so well an
inefficient extraction means that you
would get lower potency than what would
be expected well that's indeed what this
plot shows also the homogeneity of the
sample portion extracted is important if
you imagine for example a KitKat kicked
cats are nicely segmented you can break
one off and it stopped that everything
is is homogeneous but imagine if there's
medicinal compose
in there as well not all candy buyers
are separated in segmented like that
what segments did the laboratory choose
for their analysis did they choose a
portion that was not homogeneous what
were these cannabinoids localized in the
product that could significantly affect
the the final potency results Labs often
develop methods on flour that may not
transfer to more complex matrices like
food I think it's important to note and
I would be willing to bet that a lot of
people don't know that many states have
a plus or minus 15% permissible
deviation between the measured value and
the product label so that's like saying
you know if you measured a hundred
milligrams it could really be anywhere
between 85 milligrams and 115 milligrams
and things like that all of these sort
of challenges confound proper dosing how
does a patient know how much of this
stuff to be consuming if they don't know
accurately what's in in the product to
begin with so I think you know and some
with some of our laboratory audits you
know we've seen labs doing a great job
and we've seen some labs do it needing
some guidance and often the guidance
revolved around some of some key themes
st. seems like training documentation
you know how's the staff been adequately
trained things like training on the
federal status of cannabis you know if
you have a laboratory you can indeed be
arrested in some labs that we've gone
into their staff was not aware of that
which can be rather frightening to the
unsuspected laboratory personnel Labs
often show a lack of trace of the
understanding of the traceability
requirements and I can I can understand
that in a way because often you know
this industry is significantly evolving
daily and so people are trying to
scramble to get this industry off the
ground and sometimes there's things that
just haven't been thought about because
no one's ever had to do this before Labs
often lack good documentation practices
and one thing that
I find to be sometimes a problem is that
sometimes laboratory directors the
scientific directors just don't have the
the knowledge that they require to be
able to be running all of this complex
sophisticated analytical instrumentation
and ensuring that their clients are
getting sound analytical defendable data
I found this rough guide the spotting
bad science and I think a lot of these
apply to situations in the cannabis
industry
number one sensationalized headlines
we've all seen those we all kind of know
who the culprits are therefore these
sensationalized doom-and-gloom
type stories but there are things that
people are doing in the cannabis
industry that could then lead to those
sensationalized headlines such as using
too small of a sample size on
representative samples you know are we
accurately evaluating products are we an
are we measuring enough product to be
able to put one number on those
cherry-picked results these are all
types of things that I've seen in the
industry and then essentially do not
help labs have achieved defendable data
you know we don't want a situation like
this where somebody is standing on a
cliff and we've scoured through the
Pennsylvania Code you know which is
still in a state of evolution as well
since this industry is is is certainly
new to Pennsylvania but there's things
like they've recently released a
sampling document that says they're
supposed to be 8 to 10 grams for a 5 to
10-pound batch now if you take the
extremes they're a 10 a 10 gram sample
from a 5 pound batch that means that
only about point 4 percent of that batch
is being analyzed is that enough but
then they added verbiage in there to say
or a quantity the approved lab and
grower processor determines is
sufficient to perform all of the tests
well one can imagine that a nefarious
relationship between a lab and a grower
could result in the end the grower
saying hey if you know only only take
two grams and I'll continue my business
through you imagine if you're only
evaluating 2 grams for 5 pounds that
1/5 less now we're not even evaluating
point 1% of this highly complex plant in
Pennsylvania the pesticide list is yet
to be defined and so laboratories are
basically consulting with other states
to see what they views and they're
buying standards you know from places
like res Tech they're buying standards
and and they're they're evaluating the
standards that are in there but they're
not sure if those are the ones that they
should be one that kind of confuses me
is that labs are required to test for
six cannabinoids but processors are
required to label nine where are they
getting the data for those other three
cannabinoids that's going to cause some
confusion and be a potential stag here
in Pennsylvania over the last it's not
all horror stories we've seen a lot of
states become more active in pitching
legislation to to have a legalized
cannabis industry we've seen headlines
such as the top one that cannabis could
help curb the opioid emic I lived in
Colorado for two years and I did not
hear about an opioid epidemic but after
moving back to western Pennsylvania I
can tell you that it's pretty much a
nightly news occurrence something having
to do with opioid problems even the
state of Utah 76% of voters now are in
favor of legalizing medical cannabis and
even the US government in that last
article they're in The Telegraph is
saying that cannabis has been shown to
kill cancer cells so there's a lot of
there's a lot of interest now in doing
research and proper analytical science
to determine whether some of these
claims are indeed true and if they are
true how can we start to make how can we
start to allow people that have ailments
to have alleviation from their symptoms
standard methods are now being created
as we speak our JV group has several
people involved in the ASTM
International Development of standards
to date the American herbal
copia has been one of the only sources
that we've had for Standardization and
while it's a useful starting point if
you look at some of the analytical
methods there in laboratories to start
using these for example I believe the
the liquid chromatography method in the
in the document has a 36 minute runtime
labs are often using columns now and
protocols that are anywhere between 5
and 8 minutes because they're trying to
develop higher throughput so they can
evaluate more samples in a shorter
period of time you know we all talk
about the need of Standardization but
why what's the point well you can start
developing better accurate product
comparisons so if you have multiple
products and everybody's doing the same
method again that creates a much more
apples to apples comparison than what we
currently have
auditors can also better evaluate
laboratory data and labs can begin to do
things like round robins where a sample
could be sent off to multiple labs
within the specific state at least right
now and they can all evaluate that same
sample which will allow people to kind
of understand what type of sample
matrices might become problematic and it
can give some profound data on what labs
are seeing Arg lately they would help
several labs get to this point with more
defendable data on the Left I'm showing
a plot above us residual solvent
calibration curve and this lab only used
three data points when in the state of
Washington requires four so they weren't
compliant there and there are squared
was a tad low for what the state of
Washington requires we got them to do a
six point calibration and you can see
it's quite a profound difference not
only are they compliant from the amount
of calibration standards that they
needed to do and they chose to do more
than what the state required but there
are squared shows a much more linear and
accurate calibration curve microbe
failure rates are pervasive in this
industry you know in the state of
Washington we typically see around 9 to
12 percent of samples failing from micro
so when we see a lab with with
significantly low micro
you're raised we need to do our due
diligence and evaluate whether or not
they're doing this right because this is
a public safety matter and so while
we're not looking to for labs to be
failing a certain amount it just so
happens that there is an average number
of failures so on the top lab you see
that in 2015 they were only they were
only failing about two and a half
percent of their samples and we found
that they were doing that just a simple
dilution calculation error and you could
see the difference now in 2016 and 2017
they're much more they're much more
within the average of what we see from
other laboratories lab number two you
can see this extremely egregious
egregiously low failure rate in 2015
only 22 percent it would be great if
that was because the growers were not
you know the growers were doing things
very very adequately and there was just
no microbial growth on the on these
plants but indeed this lab was doing
what's called trial ABing they weren't
even measuring this they weren't even
evaluating the sample they were just
accepting the money and putting a pass
label on the product and that creates an
extreme public safety issue and one of
our auditors was savvy enough to find
out this by requesting to see their
purchase requisitions and he found that
they couldn't possibly be doing the
number of tests that they indicated
because they weren't even buying enough
product to do so so our daily group is
is essentially interested in helping
expand cannabis science that I mentioned
we helped draft Washington State's
regulations we've performed over 65
audits in Washington over the last four
to five years and we know auditors
because we are auditors so we can help a
laboratory get to where they need to be
because again we've been audited
ourselves and we've been doing this for
some time we also serve on the Emerald
Conference panel and Advisory Board I
mentioned my association with terpenes
and testing magazine I mentioned that
we're working with a s
scientists on ASTM standard methods we
have members on the research Advisory
Committee of the Pennsylvania medical
cannabis Society and we're doing
outreach to folks like you and events
like this recently we had two articles
published in turd beans and dusting
magazine kind of sharing with with the
audience and the readers are experienced
you know both from attending the m-word
conference this year and then just you
know basically kind of summarizing some
of the things I've talked about in this
presentation about this need for labs to
have defendable data so I think
essentially it comes down to a few key
things you know can if you're a consumer
in this industry you need to be asking
questions about product labels you know
products and labels and avoiding you
know the old school kind of snake oil
salesmen much of the industry is so
cloak-and-dagger you know people don't
typically know who grew the plants or
who measured them is there any
documentation for those products I think
it's extremely important for people to
understand the concept of natural
variation and in general the product
tested by the lab may not be what you're
ingesting so that number might just be a
ballpark figure but it might not you
might not be able to really clean much
from it the top right photo there shows
the New York subway and I think this
kind of really shows the the power of
natural variation we're all made of the
same stuff and yet we look different we
act different we have personalities and
that's what makes the world
great well that's what what the cannabis
plant also has that made of the same
things but it's because of these
different combinations of those things
that they have such diversity I think
it's also important as a consumer to
know that when you go into a dispensary
the bud tenders knowledge may be
anecdotal it might be from their
experience but you ultimately need to
determine what works best for you you
need to be doing self titration through
trial and error often you might not be
able to consult with your medical
doctor about these types of things
because they might just simply not know
so you need to keep track of how you
feel after ingesting specific products
and perhaps start self reporting what
worked for you and what didn't in
combating the symptoms of specific
ailments I invite you all to check out
the website of Mira datacom this is one
such entity that is developing an
application for four users to be able to
self report the effects of how these
different products have helped them in
alleviating their ailments I think it's
important just to overall be an educated
savvy consumer really it's about
everybody in this industry questioning
everything everything is brand new and
again it becomes a challenge to kind of
sift through what's scientifically
proven and what's not if you're a grower
or a cultivator ask to see your
perspective labs audit results or
training certificates even proficiency
tests and sure if you're a grower or a
cultivator and here you're providing
enough product to get accurate results I
know it's also a challenge because that
product can also be sold as a valuable
commodity but at the end of the day the
patients that are buying the products
are what matters most if you're a lab
you know don't given the pressure some
clients wanting to pay for specific
results and ensure that there's proper
training and in to your staff and and
document everything make sure that your
data is defendable you know there's a
lot of non scientists in this industry
and again it's worth repeating that just
because something appears scientific
doesn't mean it is this could be data
instrumentation scientific studies
anyone can make any claim they want but
ultimately where is the proof ask to see
the data if you are seeing data asked
what the error or standard deviation is
if they it's not provided move on if
you're looking at buying an instrument
ask how it's calibrated and validated
are there standards that can be
evaluated again if there's no data
be shown move on and ultimately do your
homework and make sure that you know
what you're getting into so when you
look out at this industry what do you
see I like this traffic because this
lady sees the globe and I look at
cannabis as a global situation not just
one in Colorado or California so what
did you see well you know I look at it
like everyone needs to be ensuring that
patients get the best quality medicine
and I don't mean just you know people
that are auditing labs people that are
you know running the analytical tests I
mean everybody that's involved in this
industry needs to be making sure that
patients are getting the best quality
you know I think it's quite important
for groups like r.j. leader to be
providing expertise and helping to
enrich the science I mean that's
consistently what we're striving to do
also to help labs assemble the
foundation for defendable analytics you
know there's gonna be people coming
after the labs we've saw it on a
previous slide with the manipulation of
data if you have defendable analytics
you should have nothing to worry about I
think it's quite important that many
entities now including ASTM
International are generating
standardized methods this is going to be
huge for this industry I think if our
jaylee group had a mantra it could be
educate train repeat until that person
that you're educating training and
training finally knows I think that
that's kind of the disciple that that
we're hoping to see astly
we've all seen movies like this you know
propaganda and quotations like this you
know Sting's like you know this is not
medicine this is a cruel hoax that
sounds like something more out of a
teaching Chong show or Nancy Grace you
know people on pods are killing whole
families and good people don't smoke
marijuana and and this is not to to
necessarily judge the negativity of
these people that are viewing this
industry this is to show you that
there's opinions like these out there
and when there's negative opinion
out there from people that have in
powerful positions such as these folks
why would anyone want to attract even
more negative attention to this industry
by doing something unethical e are not
making sure that they're putting out
quality products and that the data that
we're generating the mountains of data
that we're generating on these products
are done with analytical acumen that
patients can ultimately trust with that
I thank you and I'd be happy to answer
any questions that you may have
thank you dr. Lou Boyd for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started our first
question is do you think the industry
will be coming out with standard methods
soon that's a great question I do I do
think so you know these are these types
of standard methods are not something
that can be done overnight while we can
look at several other industries such as
nutraceuticals pharmaceuticals even
agriculture cannabis presents a very
peculiar scenario in that it's also you
know it's all of those it's it's a
medicine it's a natural product and it
can also be a food a food product and so
I think that you know organizations that
I'm affiliated with that are looking to
develop standardized methods are perhaps
rather slow-moving to the to the eyes of
others but we're definitely trying to
make sure we do our due diligence and
get it right the first time and make
sure that there's a clear path that
anybody affiliated with the industry can
can follow these methods and ultimately
you know you know those standardized
methods will be here to stay and will
require a lot of a lot of further
fine-tuning so I
would say that the short answer is is
yes there would be there will be
standardized methods being shared with
the the cannabis community at large but
again these these types of things just
can't happen overnight because they are
very complex well thank you for that
your next one is do you think
organizations will be coming out with
standard methods soon I think that ties
in to the last one where you know these
these types of organizations like ASTM
AOA see that they're already working on
on these types of things that you know
there's been some groups like the AC CL
that have been trying to evaluate
methodologies for the industry and then
you see like an organization like ASTM
doing the same thing so there's there's
many different prongs to this approach
there's a lot of people coming out with
different with different types of
standardized documents some groups have
even started to join forces and figure
why would everybody
reinvent what others have already done
and so I think that all of those efforts
will help us see this realization much
faster here we have time for one more
question
why don't labs put a potency range on
products to better represent these
sources of variation that's a great
question I've seen one lab and and one
dispensary actually utilized that system
where you would see a range of potency
now I believe that lab may have been
measuring things twice you know standard
kind of rule of thumb and analytical
chemistry as we measured things at least
three times I realize that's not very
practical for labs that are trying to
increase their throughput and help their
clients get there their products to
market but I do think that you know
while I don't know why labs haven't
chosen to do this I think part of it is
likely because it's not required by
States if it was required by States we'd
see everybody doing this and I think
that you know people involved in the
industry that feel like that that should
be something that Israel requirement you
know perhaps contacting the
the people involved in developing the
regulations would be the best way to go
about doing that but I think they you
know when we look at other products that
are that are marketed you know like food
products we don't see a range of things
we don't see a range of things like
caloric content on food we don't see a
range of you know nutritional and
vitamin information for your percent
daily values on product labels but again
like this is being this is something
that that's that's it's called medicine
and I think they the the the error
thresholds in the pharmaceutical
industry are quite tight so when you see
something that says a hundred milligrams
you know patients should be able to
trust that when we're putting something
on on a potency label that is is quite
limited you know 25 percent we don't
know all the difference you know and
you're not aware of all those different
sources of variation that can be a
challenge to properly dose so you know
I'd like to see at least some place to
start to do that out of their own accord
and share at least share with their
clients even if it's not going on the
product label people that are do
manufacturing these products would at
least have an extra piece of data to
kind of refine their processes it's a
very minimal well I would like to once
again thank dr. McCoy for his
presentation but also like to thank the
Leopards for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I'm gonna
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through June 29th to 2018 you'll receive
an email from laberd's letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that is all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye